This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts,
or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. It has been a while. I took some time off to do my final exams and I have officially finished my degree, which is super exciting, a little bit nerve-wracking as well. I think next week I really want to do an episode on like the psychology of life transitions because I think it would be quite interesting to kind of discuss especially as I prepare to move cities, say goodbye to Canberra, start my new job, all of those things.
Yeah, it feels like adulthood is really beginning and it's a period. It's pretty full of like nostalgia for like my first year self, excitement, nerves. But that's next week. For this week's episode, I'm pulling something from the archives. We're going to talk about the psychology of attraction. So I did a lot of research into this a few weeks ago, but never got around to recording it because I was obviously stressed. But today's the day.
I've just been really fascinated by what creates attraction as a single person and why we like certain people and don't like others, especially in our 20s when it seems, you know, everyone is having these flings and these attraction and these crushes. to people and we go out to clubs and, you know, we meet people and we have this spark. So what kind of creates this so-called spark from a psychological perspective? We're going to explore the answer to that. But I wanted to take more of a social psychology approach rather than biological as we traditionally hear about, you know, obviously we can't really talk about attraction without talking about the neural and hormonal origins. But I want to discuss more so how attraction forms in a
social environment for romantic partners, obviously, but also friendships as well. Why are we attracted to certain people and not others? Okay, so there is this theory, often flaunted by the skeptics of love, that attraction is merely chemical, love is merely chemical, romance, all of those things. It's quite like a biological reductionist approach that we can explain everything based on what neurotransmitters are released, what hormones are released and those kind of things. And attraction occurs because of hormones, mostly related to procreation and sex that are released when we see someone who arouses us or meets our preferences or our love map, which is something I'm going to discuss a bit later. And it's attraction, like that instantaneous attraction, it's often associated with high levels of serotonin and estrogen for women and testosterone for men. And we find people initially attractive because of what is unlocked in our brains and bodies.
Also, when I was researching this for the women who are listening or for those who identify as female or who have periods, it's really interesting because you're more likely to find people attractive during certain periods of like your menstrual cycle. So right after you like finish your period before you like begin to ovulate before you're like most fertile, I guess, that's the period where you're most likely to experience like attraction, which is really interesting and that drops off after you've ovulated towards like when your period's about to start. So attraction can be caused by things like physical appearance, obviously, but also other factors like smell. So a study that was done this year actually, well, was published this year, found that women with certain scents are more attractive to men.
So it turns out that we are most appealing when we have high estrogen and low progressive. levels, which is, like I said, around when we're ovulating. And this balance of hormones indicates high female fertility, which is a huge kind of driver of attraction. I feel like when we're thinking about it from a sex perspective or a mating perspective. And the research has explained that it makes sense that, you know, men find women more attractive while they're at this stage because of that instinct to mate and create offspring. Another one, another factor, that also has a big kind of role to play in attraction is a voice. So another study a few years ago, so a bit outdated,
but it found that women prefer men with low voices. And there could be something inherently biological in this, as deeper voices have been linked to producing healthier children in the wild, lower pitch is associated with being bigger. It might also indicate greater testosterone levels if your voice is low, which is really interesting. So smell, voice, all of these things that we initially get from someone when we first meet them. And other factors that kind of create that rush of serotonin that accompanies attraction may be certain features like muscles and how tall you are, if you have good
skin, facial traits, tan skin, posture, all of which can be indicative of someone's fertility, obviously, but also the capacity to protect, to care and to nurture. So although instant attraction might be biologically based, it's also influenced by a number of social and environmental factors that more so allow love and other feelings of attraction, but more than that to kind of blossom. Okay, but now moving on to what leads to attraction and friendship beyond that initial spark, that initial first glance, love at first sight thing. So there are four factors that psychologists often identify as leading to attraction. So that's proximity, physical attractiveness, which we've kind of already discussed, similarity and liking those who like us. So proximity is probably the strongest predictor of attraction.
The more we kind of see and interact with a person, the more likely we are to become friends with them or to become attracted to them. This is really interesting. There was a study that, you know, this was a theory at first, and there was a study done to kind of confirm this hypothesis. And it was done at the Westgate House community at MIT. So it's like a college, basically. And they tracked attraction, relationships, and friendship formation amongst people
at various apartment buildings and apartment rooms. And residents had been assigned their apartments at random, which is great. We know random allocation makes an experiment a lot more generalized. generalizable? Yes, more valid, more reliable. But researchers asked the participants to name the people that they were most attracted to and their three closest friends within the living quarters. 65% of them named people who lived on the same floor. So all people who even lived in the same apartment because it was shared. Forty-one percent of them said next door neighbors, so those right across from them.
22% said two doors down. So you can kind of see as they get farther away, the rate of attraction or friendship kind of drops off. And then 10% of them said the opposite end of the hallway. So it kind of seems that attraction and the level of friendship that we have towards people or how attracted we are to them as a person is related to just the physical distance between people. But it's not just like the physical distance.
it's also functional distance. So if there are features in your life or where you're living that make it more likely that you'll become close to someone or interact with them, that also creates attraction. So if, for example, people are living on the same pathway or someone who's living at the bottom of the stairs where you have to pass by every day, they also have a greater chance of meeting people and building those friendships, but also that attraction with people that they meet. So the proximity effect, it does seem largely to be due to mere exposure. So the mere exposure effect, it's basically the tendency to rate stimuli more positively after
you've been exposed to them repeatedly. So in the case of attraction, you rate someone as more attractive or you're more interested in them the more that you're exposed to them. So we see, the more we see people, the more familiar we become with them, the more likely we are to be attracted to them, to become friends with them, to pursue something with them. And obviously, like, there are limitations. Like, if the person's really mean, doesn't really matter how close they are. It's probably worse if they're closer to you and you don't like them.
But in general, proximity effect does seem to kind of hold up. And it's also to do with familiarity. It builds affection and liking. So the more exposure, the higher frequency of exposure, the more favorable you are. So that is one of those core things that relates to who you find attractive. It's how close you are distance-wise. The second one that we talked about that I noticed was similarity. And this really fuels growing relationships and attraction to someone.
So it's not just the physical distance, but it's match between our interests, our attitudes, values, backgrounds, or personality, and those of another person. So if you share things in common, you're more likely to find someone attractive in the more likely a relationship is to evolve. Research evidence really strongly supports that similarity draws people together. I feel like it's a bit of a no-brainer. So, you know, think about your friends or the person you're in a relationship with or someone that you like. You're more likely to share common attitudes, you have things that you like in common. For example, if you like bike riding, obviously you're going to be more attracted to someone who shares that interest. Yeah, so if you share things in common, it kind of makes sense that attraction will evolve,
especially because I guess people who are similar to us will like the same things as us, but also they validate our own characteristics and beliefs. So they provide us with this feeling that we are right, that what we like is right, that how we feel is right. And that's really important for our self-esteem, which is why we might be attracted to them because they validate us. and we also tend to make negative and automatic inferences about someone who disagrees with us on an important issue or who just likes the things that we like because that kind of provides a bit of hostility or kind of I don't know push back towards what we think is good in the world and liking is so powerful you know liking someone though if you just like who they are that it can make up for an absence of similarity So having things in common is important. But if you just really like someone, sometimes that doesn't even matter.
And this is where the principle of reciprocity comes in. So we like people who like us, which kind of links back to that self-esteem, self-awareness hypothesis. Reciprocal liking sometimes occurs because of a self-fulfilling prophecy. So when we expect people to like us, we think that they like us, that elicits more favourable behaviour from us, which means they're more likely to be favourable or kind to us back. So there was a study done, I think in the 80s,
right when like attraction psychology was starting to take place. And basically these two guys, Curtis and Miller, they got these college students to participate in pairs. And the pairs, both members of the pairs, they hadn't met each other before. And one member of each pair was selected randomly to know certain information that the other student either liked or disliked them. Obviously, this wasn't based on anything. The researchers made it up.
So they kind of like manipulated the experiment. So one member of the pair was told, oh yeah, this person that you're meeting today, they really like you or they've heard about you. And, you know, maybe in another pair, the research would be like, oh, they actually dislike you. I don't think that you guys will get along. So those who believed that they were liked initially, they behaved more positively. They disclosed more, disagreed less, and behaved just in general more warmly to their partner. Whereas those who believed they weren't liked actually ended up getting along with the person a lot less, even if initial personality tests or interest tests had proven that they actually had quite a lot in common.
So the partner kind of mirrored that of the other member of the pair. So if you thought someone wasn't going to like you, probably weren't going to be as warm to them because you were initially hostile or, you know, vigilant against an attack against your sense of self. This is obviously, maybe not obviously, but interestingly, moderated by self-esteem. So people with a negative self-concept, so they don't really like themselves,
they don't see themselves very favorably, they respond quite differently in this experiment, which the researchers noticed and would prefer to meet someone who has criticized them before who the researchers said didn't like them. If someone is, it's friendly to them and you have a negative self-concept, then that behaviour kind of appears unwarranted because you believe that you're not a good person and they may not respond positively. So that reciprocation is a huge part of attraction, liking someone who likes us. It makes a lot of sense. Obviously, the big one, the one that most people probably think about in terms of attraction, in terms of attraction, it's just physical attractiveness. You know, you just find certain people hot.
You like what they look like, I guess. And, you know, the research checks up against that. Men and women both prefer attractive partners and are more likely to say that they're more attractive. Or they have greater attraction towards them physically and greater arousal. person is traditionally attractive. This is one of the best indicators of whether someone would like to date someone. So people, they often attribute positive qualities to those who are more attractive. My friend Meg and I were talking about this other day, how attractive people have it so much easier because I think people presume that physically attractive people possess other socially
desirable traits as well because it's indicative of so much more. And our culture kind of promotes this stereotype in less than subtle ways. You know, bad characters and movies, they're often ugly, whilst the good ones are beautiful like Cinderella and Snow White, they have perfect skin, beautiful bodies. And so we see them as good, whereas those that are ugly, we see them as unhealthy, we see them as cruel, we see them as bad. And this has like a lot of research behind it. People really want to hate on attractive people. Well, not really hate on attractive people, but they want to know why they kind of get further ahead in life, I guess.
So here's a few examples of how this attraction or attractiveness creates attraction or liking someone. So teachers, they often judge attractive students as more intelligent and unattractive students. Adults and nurses who are in pediatric wards, they often punish unattractive children more harshly. This study in Texas showed that a judge is more likely, or judges just correlationally, set lower bales and smaller fines for attractive suspects.
Attractive people make more money, they get better job ratings from their bosses. And this one is really interesting in terms of attachment and childhood development. Parents, they spend more time looking at attractive babies. And attractiveness of babies, if the baby was really cute, was linked to health and treatment in ICU. So nurses and doctors, not to say they're biased, this is obviously very implicit, but they tend to spend more time nurturing and caring for babies that look attractive, that look cute. So even in early life, it's really good to be good looking.
You know, there's just other things as well, like attractive people, they're more seen as relaxed and outgoing. And that's a huge thing for attraction. If you think that someone has all of these desirable traits, just from looking at, you at them, obviously, that attraction is going to blossom pretty quickly. And it does create kind of a self-fulfilling prophecy. So because attractive people are more valued and favored, even from birth, this causes them to develop greater self-confidence. And if they're more liked, they might want that feeling to continue. So what ends up happening is they get more opportunities.
they're more valued so that those other kind of attributes and skills and behaviours that make someone attractive or likable develop from that. And just in terms of like general attractiveness, it's really interesting to note that there is like a lot of cross-cultural consistency in terms of body features and what kind of people we're going to find attractive just from the surface level. So across different cultures, women, In terms of their facial structure, we like people with large and widely separated eyes, small nose, small chin, but also wide cheekbones and narrow cheeks.
So if you think about the traditional model, like the Kendall Jenner's of the world, they have all those features. Men on the other hand, very different. We want a square jaw, we want small eyes, thin lips, bushy eyebrows, those kind of things. And a lot of people from different cultures agree on what it's attractive in a face. There's been so many studies that have shown that people across the world find the same types of faces very attractive. And even infants show this. They prefer the same photographs of adults and they're often the attractive adults,
which I think is really interesting in terms of whether attraction to certain features is made even biological and linked to that health and well-being kind of perspective. So attraction towards physical features may be where the idea of love at first sight has come from. We see it in movies and in books. It's a classical archetype of love of seeing someone and falling in love with them, knowing the other one. But is this really real? Is this a real thing? I think a more important mechanism by which humans become captivated by someone,
It's due to your love map. This was a concept created by a sexologist called John Money, very good name. So long before you fixate on a specific person that you find attractive for various reasons, you've developed a map. It's kind of like a template within your brain that determines what arouses you sexually, what drives you to fall in love with one person rather than another, what drives you to be friends with one person rather than another, to find someone attractive, basically.
And these love maps, they vary from one individual to the next. So some people get turned on, you know, by a business suit or a doctor's uniform, large, large boobs, small feet, laughter. It's all kind of varied, but that averageness and that kind of notion of symmetry still wins out. So in this one study, these psychologists selected 32 faces of Caucasian women only. and using computers they averaged all of their features and then they showed these images to college peers and of the 32 photographs of real female faces only three of them were rated as more appealing than these mixed photos of all the averaged features so that's really interesting this kind of idea of averageness and symmetry is really important and they don't really know why um obviously The world does not share the same sexual ideals of Caucasian students from some university in America.
But like I said, despite widely dissimilar standards of beauty and sex appeal, there are some of those common traits, like the symmetry of the face, the small nose, the large eyes, good complexion. People are also drawn to partners and attracted to people who they regard as clean, which makes sense because you don't want to date someone. who has poor hygiene, that is really grossed. And men in most places, they generally prefer plump, wide-hipped women to slim ones, women prefer broad-shouldered men. So it looks really count in attraction. And so does money, which makes sense.
Obviously, the initial attraction, you might not be able to determine how much someone is worth, maybe by the value of their clothes or something like that. But if you find out that someone has a lot of money or they're pretty, well off, you could become more attracted to them. And this is seen from rural Zulus to urban Brazilians, you know, Caucasian people in Wyoming. Men are attracted to young, good-looking women, while women are drawn to men with property and money. And these like male, female appetites, they're probably innate. You know, it's in a male's genetic advantage to fall in love and be attracted to a woman who provides and who could produce viable offspring. And it's in a woman's
biological advantage traditionally and from an evolutionary standpoint to be attracted to a man who can help her support a young family or, you know, offspring. This can influence love at first sight because we're often immediately captivated by characteristics that fit our love map and feel an insane attraction to that person if they kind of check off things that in our brain circuitry we know would make us happy and aroused and give us that serotonin rush. And then I think the other thing is we also create expectations for this person that we have this instantaneous attraction for.
And when people meet those expectations, it's a self-fulfilling prophecy that makes you kind of feel like you've loved them since the beginning, since you first laid eyes on them. Another important consideration in terms of love at first sight or attraction is that it might have a critical adaptive function amongst animals, and including humans. So during the mating season, a female squirrel, for example, needs to breed.
And if she sees a healthy squirrel who probably doesn't fit her love map, but maybe the biological, physical map of what is a good partner, she really shouldn't waste any more time. She should size him up, see if he's right. And if he looks suitable, she'd probably grab the chance to copulate.
She needs to have babies. That's what her instinct is driving her towards. So perhaps love at first sight, it's no more than an inborn tendency in many creatures that has evolved to spur the mating process. And then among our human ancestors, what has been animal attraction involved into a human sensation of infatuation at a glance and love at first sight. So we've talked about proximity, we've talked about similarity, reciprocal feelings, what else, physical attractiveness. But then there's familiarity. And this might be the most important.
important factor that kind of runs through them all. When research participants rated the attractiveness of faces, they rated the faces that most matched or looked like their own as the most attractive. This is because people who are similar to us will also feel familiar to us. And it's reciprocal liking again, people who look like each other. If we see someone a lot, and we begin to understand their faces have become familiar to us. And that makes us feel comfortable and it makes us feel acknowledged in some ways and validated, which I just think is really interesting, like how that kind of comes about, how we, you know, people who are familiar are more attractive because of that proximity, but also because we become to understand their facial features
and feel a sense of comfort around them. So let's jump into some theories of interpersonal attraction, which has kind of been coming towards this. So there are a few. The first one, the most prominent idea in psychology is social exchange theory. This is the idea that people's feelings about attraction and a relationship depends on the perceptions of rewards and costs. The kind of relationship they deserve and their chances for having a better relationship with someone else. We really want to find the best relationship that we can get. So the rewards that we might, you know, kind of way up when we first find someone attractive, are the positive gratifying aspects of a potential relationship
that make it worthwhile. This might include things like status and physical attractiveness or money, as we were considering before. But then there's the costs, and all friendships and relationships, they have some costs. However, if rewards outweigh costs, will probably pursue that person we find attractive. And this is all dependent on comparison level
relative to expectations, experience, alternatives. if a relationship doesn't match our comparison level of what we expect, we will be unhappy. And it really depends on our point of view. People with a low comparison level, they're more likely to stay in costly relationships, which is quite sad. Like if you don't believe you can do better,
that first person you find attractive might just be the one and you might just stick it out with them. There's another idea of equity theory. And this is the idea that people are happiest in relationships where they initially feel attracted to someone when the rewards and costs experienced are shared by both parties equally. So basically what that means is neither one is giving too much.
You know, you're not going to be attracted to someone who never texts you back or maybe you will or who, you know, makes you feel like they don't want you there or that they don't like you. We're going to be attracted to someone who gives as much as we give into a relationship. And equitable relationships, they're the most happy. and the most stable. And it's a pretty powerful social norm equity. We want both people to benefit
equally and people kind of prefer to be the one who benefits more. So it's more of a problem for those who are under-benefited. So making sure that it's an equal kind of standing is really good for those long-term relationships. Let's kind of break down that cycle of long-term loving relationships because we have that initial intense liking stage of attraction, and that's called passionate love. But that kind of moves on to companion love as we know someone more when that initial attraction, that excitement, that spark begins to fade. So starting with passionate love, it's kind of been what we've been talking about this whole time. It tends to refer to attraction and love that's characterized by high arousal, intense attraction and fear of rejection. The important aspect is
that the person has to attribute arousal to the right target for passionate love to emerge. So sometimes we can confuse arousal and love. And this is called excitation transfer. Excitation transfer, I don't think many people, it's not really like a big theory in psychology, which I'm kind of surprised about because it makes a lot of sense. And it comes from this study called love on the bridge. So there's two bridges. One bridge has a tendency to tilt.
and sway and feel unstable and kind of shake around. And the other bridge feels a lot safer. It does not sway. It's not that high up. It's made of concrete. It's very stable. The first bridge, obviously, is going to generate a lot more arousal. So we have these participants, male participants,
and they were approached on either of the bridges by an attractive female experimenter. And that experimental, they asked the participant to tell them a story about a relationship. And in the suspension bridge condition, where there's a swaying and an instability, the men wrote more sexual stories and were more likely to call the experimenter to see if their date with this attractive female confederate went well. However, those in the controlled safe bridge condition wrote significantly less sexual stories and only 13% of them called the experimenter. So this is evidence of excitation transfer. participants on the unsafe bridge were more aroused but attributed this arousal to meeting the woman, not the bridge, whereas those on the safer bridge didn't feel that same level of physiological arousal. So kind of what this all comes down to is romantic love.
We have that attraction, but how does that create romantic love? Interestingly enough, a lot of research has been done into this, and romantic love seems to have a lifespan. passionate love has a lifespan more like it. That attraction is only really going to last 18 to 20 months. So, you know, if you're lucky, you've got like a year, oh, two years, sorry, like a year and a half, two years of that attraction. And after that, when relationships do last, companion love appears to be what really sustains a relationship. And this refers companion love. This refers to affection we feel for those whom our lives are deeply entwined to. It's a secure trusting partnership.
So most common responses amongst married couples have been together for more than 15 years when asked about how their married lasted is that their partner is their best friend, or they like their partner as a person. So what enables these kind of close relationships to form? That is what we are going to discuss in this next segment, I guess. Okay, so there are three important factors that enable close relationships. Number one, attachment style. Number two, equity, which we kind of already talked about. Number three is self-disclosure. Starting with attachment style. So attachment theory, it's really
really popular these days in pop culture, but it suggests that a particular, we learn a particular attachment style as infants from our caregivers. And this kind of becomes our working model and what attraction and relationship should look like later in life. There's kind of a bit of debate about how many there are, but I think they're therefore. So secure, this is rooted in trust and marked by intimacy. Preoccupied, it's marked by someone's own sense of unworthiness and anxiety within a relationship. We have dismissive, this is an avoidant relationship marked by distrust for others and fearful, and it's an avoidant relationship marked by a fear of rejection. So those with secure attachment styles are most successful in romantic relationships where attraction has initially formed or
passionate love has initially formed. They also appear to have more enduring relationships and they report more satisfaction. It's important though, I think we see a lot of like TikToks and Instagram reels and it's everywhere about what your attachment style is and it's not predictive. It is in part determined by the person you're with, their behavior and the state of your relationships. And human brains are also plastic so you can change what your attachment style is and unlearn schemers or things that you've learned from your parents. or other caregivers or people around you. Equity.
So this is a condition under which the outcomes that people receive are proportional to what they contribute to a relationship. So people in a stable, long-term relationship, they're unconcerned with short-term equity and tend not to keep track of what they're giving and receiving. And this is a really healthy long-term equity strategy. If you're not keeping track of who's giving more, you often tend to be happier because it always comes around.
Finally, self-disclosure, and this is the thing I kind of find most interesting. So this kind of refers to revealing intimate aspects of one's self to others, and this really creates greater attraction and a more deep attraction and connection. So in persistent growing relationships, partners often show increasing self-disclosure, and this seems to be driven by principles of disclosure reciprocity and the tendency to match each other's level of self-disclosure. Attraction, like we've discussed, it builds from biology, but it is moulded by our environment,
and we can eventually create long-lasting, stable love from that initial spark if we follow kind of some of those almost rules of equity and self-disclosure and trust. But I just think it's really interesting. You know, we've kind of investigated and talked about that initial feeling and that hormonal rush, you know, due to voice. due to smell and due to attractiveness. But then when we add in factors like proximity and familiarity, reciprocity and similarity, it shows that, you know, it's kind of almost deterministic who we fall for, who we find
attractive. It's probably, you know, someone you live close to, someone you see a lot, someone who you have things in common with, someone from your neighborhood. So we may not have as much choice as we think. Anyhow, I hope that episode was informative. I hope that you've learned something about maybe your. type, your love map, what makes you attracted to certain people and not to others. And I think that's super important in our 20s. We're attracted to a lot of people. People are really attractive. We're all
wanting to bang because, I don't know, it's that time. So knowing like why you fall for those certain people is really important, I think, or just interesting to know, like next time you find yourself having a crush. Think about some of those factors that we've talked about. You know, is it just because they're like your next door neighbor or just because you both like Star Wars or something like that. Obviously not to be taken too seriously. I'm not a professional. But I hope that you enjoyed this episode and I'm yeah, I'm back on the podcast grind. So more episodes are coming in the future. I think next week we're definitely going to talk about the psychology of life transitions, which is a huge thing for your 20s and yeah, that anxiety around it as well. And if you like this
episode, remember to subscribe the podcast. It's on Apple, Spotify. Google, so many other places. And thanks to all the support and thanks for bearing with me while I had a little break. Can't wait to record a few more things soon. And thank you for listening. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side.
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.